außergewöhnliche gäste heute bei pixum
bevor ich also die frage wie ist die
lage stelle
wir haben heute die leute hier die eine
extrem erfolgreiche facebook seite
machen das heißt ihre seite ist berühmt
ihr selber sei das noch nicht so richtig
aber das ändert sich heute mit diesem
topf und sag mal wer seid ihr
wie ist die lage ganz gut im mikro
immerhin hast du immer wir haben ja die
lage ist ganz gut
wir freuen uns dass wir hier sind ein
bisschen länger gebraucht dass wir hier
kopf hin kommt aber schmeckt ja eine
andere fan seite die ist dann im rahmen
der besprechung terminfindung ist er
dann von facebook abgeschaltet worden
wie ist da das risiko wie sieht das bei
euch aus besteht ein risiko oder seid
ihr sicher bei uns ja wir sind ziemlich
sicher aber es halt bei facebook immer
so dass man mal was posted was
vielleicht an schließlich einen kleinen
gruppen sind dann melde die das ganz
schnell
kennst du bist vielleicht auch dass die
ich kenne das nicht nein nein wir uns
wir posten doch mal so schwarzem humor
zwischendurch und für manche leute ist
das dann eher an schließlich so
moralapostel in der richtung und werden
melden dass dann ist man vielleicht für
24 stunden blockiert aber dann macht er
es dann weiter und aber es passiert
nicht mehr so häufig okay dieses
überhaupt dazu gekommen
ihr habt ihr angefangen das ist
mittlerweile im kongo lebt hat
irgendwann sich gedanken gemacht aber
schon typ der ziemlich auf internet und
hier damals network fixiert war auf
jeden fall hat er sich gedacht einfach
mal so eine seite zu machen dazu ist es
dann irgendwie auch gekommen lief dann
am anfang ein bisschen ja
langsamer verständlicherweise aber
ebenfalls ob 20.000 unglaublich so
irgendwie der schalter klick gemacht
genau der hat genug zum selbstläufer
geworden
die leute sehen die reichweite ist
gestiegen und das hat sich dann
irgendwie ganz schon 400.000 er wollte
eigentlich nur die wollte auch haben wir
das eigentlich ganz witzig weil du mal
schwarz bin hat perfekt gepasst
und dann ist das so ein selbstläufer
geworden spruch ist ja auch ziemlich
bekannt das heißt wenn ich das
erfolgsrezept zusammensetze
zusammenzähle korrigiert mich wenn ich
falsch liege
also man muss humor haben
ich muss selber dietrich sein ich glaube
wenn man selber oder meine vermutung
wäre wenn man nicht selber witzig ist
keine witzigen ideen hat funktioniert
das schätzt das zweite ist man sollte
vielleicht zu mehreren sein damit man
ich sage mal eine breite auch von
verbinden können trifft und was würde
ihr noch sagen sehen sind das die beiden
punkte konsequenz das stimmt wir können
nicht einfach eine konsequenz heißt
wirklich es gibt viele die posten
vielleicht mal zwei drei sachen für
sachen merken dann okay jetzt habe ich
knapp 200 leichtes läuft nicht mehr so
in thailand auf aber wirklich das
dranbleiben ist da wirklich das
wichtigste also wenn man wirklich
tagtäglich lampe ist auch schon richtig
strukturiert als wir schon unsere tage
wo jeder so und so viele sachen postet
weil das wirklich schon so ist also
anmerkte die reichweite steigt und sinkt
das thema stetig so ein wechsel also
muss man schon dran bleiben damit das
auch wirklich läuft das heißt ihr macht
das fliegen wie viele unserer kanäle
auch ihr habt den verhaltet euch wie ein
sender genau der wird es gibt einen plan
gebaut also ungefähr nur ein bisschen
kleinen format ja eigentlich schon
und wie macht ihr habt euren schichten
heute morgen du ja eigentlich schon also
jeder zu seiner aufgaben zu erfüllen der
eine post beispielsweise videos der
andere sprüche der andere bilder und
mittlerweile also es gab dabei weil wir
eigentlich schon ziemlich verpassen
also schon paar von uns wirklich einige
sachen vergessen mit dabei haben wir das
ganze so im griff bekommen das ist schon
ziemlich flüssig läuft und hat sich das
ausgewirkt als er das so wirklich im
griff sind da die quoten nach oben
gelangt ja eigentlich schon also als wir
irgendwann so gemerkt haben das muss
natürlich mischung ist an bildern also
irgendwann merkt man okay das kommt gut
an das läuft bei dem limit sollte
vielleicht bleiben damit das irgendwie
gut ankommt und damit es nicht zu viel
wird und das zeigt sich dann auch an den
zahlen jedenfalls also ist auf jeden
fall so dass man sagen kann stetig
steigt die anzahl der fans abonnenten
wie auch immer und das geht eigentlich
weiter immer nach oben
also wer weiß wozu das noch führt